we announced earlier this week that uh
after uh well 28 years of doing a talk
show day in and day out
that we were going to be wrapping things
up here on june 24th
sort of saying goodbye to this chapter
and then moving on to the next chapter
right
and uh i have to tell you uh response
from a lot of people has been very nice
um but you know i gotta say
when you go through a change like this
it gets a guy thinking
about stuff you know and without
sounding too highfalutin
i've started to wonder a little bit
about gee 28 years
on tv day in and day out every night
what's my impact been what have i meant
to the world
these are just natural questions you
know have i really made a difference
what have i uh what's my legacy going to
be
uh on this spinning blue globe we call
earth
i got a little bit of a hint of this
yesterday
apparently there was a massive variety
show in korea
and the stars of this variety show
of course was the boy band bts these
guys are
huge biggest band in the world usually
bts massive and on the variety show
bts they played a game where the
producers showed a picture of a
celebrity
to bts and then one of the guys in the
band has to identify the celebrity
um this just came out just saw it
last night and we'll take a look
wow
he called me curtain well it's like the
whole world is
convening to wish you well on your new
endeavor and you know we're drawing the
curtain
on are he probably said i was a curtain
i've been to korea i know i've been
there
you're quite popular i was popular
curtain curtain
i'll get you bts oh i'll get you good
and by that i mean i'll silently resent
you i have no power to do anything to
you
i you're going to go on to have huge
success
yes we're old and you're young
i'm very old and on the way out and you
guys are pretty much running
the world so when i say i'll get you i
just mean i'm going to stew in my own
juices
for quite a long time and you'll be
vastly unaware
of
you